hey there welcome to yet another episode
a thrilling episode of Conan O'Brien
needs a friend joined by my loyal gang
my Chums my comrades Sonam obsessian hi
good to see you good to see you no
you've been practicing that that's good
and um
and Mr Matt gorley Matt how are you hi
good to see you
very your citizenship classes are going
very well I love America
it's a beautiful country I can turn
right at a red light
I'm feeling good because I just got back
from a uh a lengthy stay in New York
City yeah did a bunch of podcast records
there very cool and what we do is we
sort of get some of the people that
don't often get to this host and our
great book or Paula Davis lined up just
a murderer's row of people to talk to
um I'm sorry what so many of those
people come out to Los Angeles regularly
many of them live here many of them live
here and it's like you caught them when
they were in New York so don't don't do
that yeah it's brutal well first of all
uh you do have a point there that every
single person I talk to not only uh
regularly comes to Los Angeles but of
the I think seven people I interviewed
uh during my week
um I think six of them own homes within
300 feet of this building yeah
um yeah I mean that that's that's the
part that's really hard to swallow yeah
it is
in people uh last week and I know you
guys were very jealous that I talked to
Matthew Reese yes your big Matthew Reese
fans and I I don't know if it's gonna
console you or not but as amazing as he
was on zoom in person multiply that by a
thousand what's he smell like
he smells like Victory and Pine
like if you can take the pine scent plus
v just the smell of Victory oh my God so
like if you if you built a log cabin out
of uh The Assault on Omaha Beach yes
exactly yeah that's uh reference to
D-Day yes I know it is I just you
probably know you probably think we
attacked a beach in Omaha Nebraska but
that you know what that probably smelled
a lot like death so I like you know I
don't think that it was probably a good
example no coast of France nice Briny
smell Beautiful yeah you kind of I
understand you're going a little hard at
him but you kind of came a little hard
to marry I don't know that's true it's
weird when you two fights yeah we have
to have a united front here because he's
the one screwing us I know he went off
to New York I went to New York and you
know what ever you know what's
incredible is uh I looked at my I was
wearing an Apple Watch and an aristocrat
fancy man
sorry I do live in a bubble
but I I own one of those watches made by
the Apple company
and it had comes complete with an apple
strap oh powered by Apple energy no but
I was wearing one just because you know
you like to know what steps you're
getting and I it's shocking this show is
sponsored by better help so I know
you're uh very busy yeah you've got
twins yes twins who are over two now
they're gonna be two in July it's very
easy to find yourself uh doing things
for other people or uh trying to be
really productive and get a lot done and
take care of everybody I know you're a
caretaking personality yeah I am so are
you and and what happens sometimes is
you'd realize I haven't checked in on
myself I have no clue how I'm doing yeah
and I bring this up because I'm a big
believer in talk therapy if you if you
can find the right fit right person and
getting help it's made a huge difference
in my life and in some ways I've been
your therapist over the years you have
been you've been and I and I think that
you're if you didn't want to pray I
don't want to pay someone so I figured
if I could just talk to you I'll just do
it for free but it is so it is important
to talk to someone if you're thinking of
starting therapy maybe give better help
a try here's what I like about
betterhelp it's entirely online this
didn't exist back in the day when I was
maybe looking for someone to talk to and
it's such a smart way to get involved in
this process better help is designed to
be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule find more balance with
better help I really think this is a
terrific idea visit betterhelp.com Conan
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Conan when you're in
New York and I'm just walking around
doing things and one day I did 10 miles
and then I think you're in Los Angeles
you know I get in my car I come here to
the podcast studio and then this is my
choice I'm carried by my assistant David
yes up and placed in my chair yeah and
then I'm carried back to my car and I go
home and then this is a deal I have with
my wife where I'm carried upstairs okay
and so I barely move here in La yeah but
I got so much I was just walking and
walking and I have killer abs right now
my ass is rock hard
do you want to see my ass yeah no I'm
good wait your your birthday's coming up
I'll make sure
five o'clock tomorrow morning ass pick
text
happy birthday like what is this one
cheek birthday on the other why did
someone send me a picture of these two
soggy uncooked English muffins
oh no wait oh wait a minute
why are they freckled English muffins
come on that's erotic I like English
muffin did you say that's erotic I think
it's very erotic okay that's my ass
ladies they've been soaked in Brine and
then just taken out they were never put
through a toaster
pickles yeah they have little freckles
uh yeah and then of course that tattoo
um we won't talk about that it's of an
Apple Watch yeah
yeah yeah it is uh it is amazing it was
incredible but I uh I did miss you guys
sincerely I did miss you but I think the
interviews were uh really terrific and
um in no way hampered by our absence but
I also missed you and I think it was a
great loss but at the same time I think
if anything the interviews were enhanced
but I think the quality really suffered
there I've covered all my tastes
you can walk in L.A I'm just saying you
know I mean I I have a very intro like
not love hate it's more I don't know
what it is with New York City right and
I I mean anytime someone says you could
do this and you're like you could do
that here too you just walk somewhere
else yeah oh wait a minute okay uh not
really true because I've tried taking
walks like my dream is to be able to
ride my bike I I did get to talk to one
guest who rides their bike everywhere
all through New York City it's a
surprise guest and it's a big deal rides
their bike all over New York City and
I'm you know how much I love riding a
bike and you got a doordash delivery
person on the podcast
yes wow we didn't have anyone that day
so I ordered a Caesar salad
um no we I just
I would love to be able to ride my bike
it's very hard to do that in LA from say
where I live to here because I live 175
miles away from this state yeah yeah
um but that's on me uh but it is hard
also to walk in L.A sometimes you're
walking you're trying to walk someplace
and the sidewalk just stops that doesn't
happen in New York City the sidewalk
doesn't just stop anywhere but you don't
have to stop you can keep walking into
the street are you working yeah you can
oh sure you can yeah and then you're
immediately hit by a truck I've been hit
by trucks 15 times yeah yeah well I
don't think is New York really a safe
place to ride a bike because I've opened
my door and hit a bike well it's not
safe clearly when you're opening doors
you're supposed to check Sona so when
you're kicking a door open and saying
death to all bikers and they go flying
over the door then no it's not a good
place to hang not at all
but yeah I don't know if it's safe is it
safe to bike I don't think it's safe yes
there's a lot it's much better because
there are a lot of uh bike Lanes okay
what you have to watch out for is uh
many more people have electric bikes and
there are a lot of delivery people and
they're going 140 miles an hour yes and
they've put they've like strapped sharp
knives to the front of their bikes it's
like Road Warriors yeah it's like Road
Warrior uh that's a little tricky yeah I
would love to be able to ride my bike to
work the only way I could do it is if I
bought a really big pickup truck and
just did little uh figure eights in the
back on my bike
you drove me to work oh okay all right
sure I won't break sudden and for
reasons I don't understand while I'm
taking these tight circles I go
that Three Stooges curly noise the whole
time I'm spinning around